es momento de hablar de economía en
france 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero luís méndez luis
bienvenido iniciamos en eeuu porque el
senado se acerca a la aprobación de un
plan de infraestructura por un valor de
un billón de dólares
así es valentina y es una de las
apuestas del presidente estadounidense
de joe bayrén dentro del plan de
reactivación económica en ese país se
espera que este plan sea aprobado en las
próximas horas por los integrantes del
senado esta ley entre otras cosas
proporcionaría incentivos fiscales para
la fabricación limpia y además se
establece universidades comunitarias
gratuitas por un espacio de dos años
entre otras cosas incluye 550 mil
millones de dólares en nuevas
inversiones para carreteras puentes y
acceso a internet por otro lado el
diario the new york times señala que el
senado podría tener listo un proyecto de
ley para un plan de 35 billones de
dólares con ello pretenden hacer frente
a los gastos para atención médica
cuidado de niños y ancianos el cambio
climático entre otros aspectos cambiamos
de tema y ahora vamos a perú porque
continúa la preocupación por la
depreciación de la moneda en ese
y es que de acuerdo con especialistas el
sol la moneda de perú ha registrado una
caída por encima del 13 por ciento a lo
largo de este año adicionalmente el 30
de julio sufrió una nueva caída que
ubicó el valor de la divisa
estadounidense por encima de los 4 soles
por dólar esto marcando un nuevo hito
histórico para la nación de acuerdo con
el diario peruano 'el comercio' el tipo
de cambio cerró en 4 soles con 11
centavos al 9 de agosto para los
expertos y de acuerdo con la publicación
financian times' la incertidumbre
política tras la llegada de pedro
castillo ha presionado el tipo de cambio
en la nación y ésta se incrementó el
comienzo de la presente semana tras la
declaraciones de quito pedido escuchemos
y toba en ese camino
los sectores estratégicos deben estar en
manos del gobierno todo es en diálogo
nadie puede tener una isla la economía
no es una isla
louis y seguimos en américa latina
porque el presidente de argentina
alberto fernández anunció un plan para
el empleo de los jóvenes así es
valentina y en este caso se destaca que
en la nación la tasa de desocupación
general se ubica por el orden del 10
como 2 por ciento en la población pero
entre los jóvenes de 14 a 29 años la
tasa se incrementa a 24,9 por ciento
para las mujeres y 17% para los hombres
en este sentido el plan del gobierno
argentino se orienta a la preparación de
los jóvenes para que puedan acceder a
puestos de trabajo en programación de
acuerdo con la agencia de noticias efe
el sector generó alrededor de 6 mil 37
millones de dólares en exportaciones
durante el año 2019
el anuncio llega luego de que miles de
personas protestaron por el aumento del
desempleo y la pobreza en el país
escuchemos
resistimos porque estamos convencidos
porque sabemos que vivimos en un país
injusto porque sigo haciendo juego bien
y sigo reclamando justicia porque sigo
siendo joven y sigo reclamando libertad
porque sigo siendo joven y quiero que
seamos solidarios porque sigo siendo
joven y quiero reclamar igualdad y
pasamos ahora europa porque grecia
recibió recursos para el plan de
recuperación es una cantidad de 4 mil
millones de dólares entregadas de euros
perdón que entregado por la comisión
europea y forma parte de un anticipo
para lo que es su plan de recuperación
vale recordar que el plan de
recuperación de grecia requiere unos 30
mil 500 millones de euros y el país
recibirá entre transferencias y
préstamos durante los próximos cinco
años los recursos están destinados para
impulsar la recuperación económica tras
la pandemia con grecia serían cuatro los
estados miembros que ya han recibido un
porcentaje de prefinanciación que en
total abarca el 13 por ciento cambiamos
de tema y es que el líbano crece la
preocupación por la escasez de
combustible una situación que se suma a
la crisis económica que atraviesa el
país y tomo matices violentos en la
jornada del 9 de agosto el líbano
enfrenta meses de grave escasez de
combustible que ha provocado largas
filas en las estaciones de servicio y
además ha provocado fallas en el
suministro de energía la escasez se
atribuye al contrabando el acaparamiento
y la incapacidad del gobierno con de
liquidez para asegurar entregas de
combustible importado la crisis empeoró
luego de que el gobierno decidió
suspender los subsidios a este producto
bueno y por último tenemos la cifra al
día tiene que ver en este caso con los
más de 4 mil millones de dólares que
requiere la empresa latam para hacer
frente al capítulo 11 de la ley de
quiebras en eeuu con ello estaría
saliendo de esta situación en la que
ingresó por entre otras cosas la crisis
provocada por la pandemia pues muchas
gracias por toda esta información
económica ustedes por su sintonía
continúan con nosotros
[Música]